[Music]
today I'm going to show you everything
you need to know to start using reactive
forms in angular 6 effectively we'll do
this by building five different forms
that started the absolute basics then
progress on to topics like dynamic form
fields validation and submitting your
form data to a back-end database almost
all apps use forms in some capacity so
understanding reactive forms is a very
valuable skill to have as an angular
developer if you're new make sure to
subscribe and grab the source code from
angular firebase comm and I'll be giving
away three free hats on Friday all you
have to do is leave a comment on this
video I'll be starting off here from an
angular 6 project and the first thing
I'll do is add angular material to this
project because it has some awesome UI
elements for form validation you can
install it in your project by running ng
add angular slash material then I've
already generated five different
components that I'm going to use to
demonstrate these different reactive
form examples if you don't know how to
generate components with the CLI make
sure to watch episode 104 from last week
the reactive forms module isn't included
by default so we're going to import that
from angular forms and then we have a
bunch of modules that were importing
from angular material that handled
different form fields that we want to
use then all of these modules will be
added down to the import section giving
us access to these various components
and services when it comes to angular
material there's a whole bunch of
different form elements that you can use
so make sure to check out the docs and
experiment with some of the examples
there
the first reactive form we'll build
starts with the absolute basics let's
see how we can set up a few form
controls for an email a message and a
select field for a career then we'll
observe the changes to the actual values
being entered into this form you'll
notice that every time we enter
something into this form it updates the
value object that's because under the
hood the form is using rxjs to treat the
form as a reactive real-time stream
let's go ahead and jump into the type
script for this component and we'll take
a look at what we need to build the
reactive form there's really two things
you need to know to get started and
that's form group and form builder form
group is the actual class that we use to
tie different form controls together
into a
single unified form form builder is just
a service that we can use to make
building forms easier so the first thing
you'll deal with pretty much any
reactive form is to clear the variable
type to the form group and we'll do this
in every single one of the demos the
next thing we'll do is add the form
builder service to the constructor of
this component then we'll create a data
model for this form during ng on an it
you can think of this as a schema for
the data that holds the actual values
and validation rules for the fields
inside your form we call form builder
group and then we set email and then we
can provide an empty string which
defines the default value most forms
will start off empty but if you want to
set a default value you can just define
it here and that's really all it takes
to build a reactive form in the
typescript but you might also want to
extract the data from this form and the
typescript as well the form group has a
method on it called value changes that
returns an observable if we subscribe to
that observable it's going to emit the
value of the form every time it changes
that's how it was able to console.log
every value change in the demo now we
need to connect this form group to the
HTML and bind it with our angular
material UI components for every
reactive form you'll bind this form
group attribute to the form you defined
in the type script and if you want to
see the value of the form in the HTML
you can just call a my form value and
then use that JSON pipe from there we'll
add a material form field and an HTML
input with the matte input directive so
that's just plain angular material to
connect it to the reactive form we call
a form control name and give it the name
of the attribute that we defined in the
type script we can go ahead and follow
the same pattern for all of the other
fields in our form and again the only
special thing we need to do is call form
control name everything else is just a
plain angular material form the one
thing you might notice about forms is
that there's a lot of markup code that
you have to deal with to avoid leaving
you at the big bowl of code soup I want
to start looking at ways we can keep our
reactive forms dry very early on the
second demo we'll look at is a nested
form what's special about this form is
that we have a parent form group and
then we have a couple of nested forms
inside of it for each of these phone
numbers for the form bow
you can see that we have a nested object
inside the forum for each of these phone
numbers let's take a look at how we can
use nesting to keep our forms organized
we have the same setup as our previous
basic form but this time we'll create a
reusable form group that we can use
multiple times in the parent form again
we call form builder group and then
we'll add a couple of default values
here for the various parts of the phone
number then we'll define the parent in
the same way by calling form builder
group we can nest the schema that we
defined for phone numbers multiple times
within this form so maybe we have a home
phone number and also a cell phone
number then if we switch over the HTML
the initial markup is exactly the same
but there's one key difference when
dealing with a nested group instead of
using form control name we'll set up a
div and pass it the form control group
name this will be our cell phone group
then inside the context of cell phone we
can start adding our inputs which will
take the form control name so we can
control the cell phone that way and then
we can do the same thing for the home
phone as well so that works okay if you
have two phone numbers but what if the
user can dynamically add as many phone
numbers as they want using this nested
form technique with ten phone numbers
wouldn't be maintainable at all in the
next demo we're going to look at form
array which allows us to dynamically add
fields to the form instead of
hard-coding in the form markup we'll
just add a button here that allows the
user to add as many phone numbers as
they want and it will add a new field
for each one to our reactive form you'll
notice that instead of a nested object
we now have a nested array of objects
and because every element in an array
has an index we can allow the user to
delete any phone numbers that they've
already added to the form the initial
form setup is very similar but we also
need to import form array from angular
forms from there we can set up a phone's
property on the form and instead of
making this a nested form it'll be a
form array that just starts out with an
empty array then the next thing we want
to do is set up a getter to retrieve the
phones from the form this is technically
optional but getters will make your life
a lot easier when working with reactive
forms as we'll see here in the upcoming
demos we can have this method return the
phones from the form and we'll make sure
to return that as a form array
then the next thing we need to do is set
up a function that will run every time a
button is clicked to add a new field to
the form let's call this the add phone
method and we'll first set up a variable
that defines our form builder group then
we can use the getter to return the form
array from the reactive form and we'll
call push on it with this new form group
that handles adding a form group
deleting a form field is even easier
when we loop over them we'll be able to
get the index then we can simply call
form array remove at this index and that
removes it from the reactive form the
HTML markup is going to start out
exactly the same as before but now that
we have an array we're going to call
form array name with that phone's
property then because we're dealing with
an array we're going to need to loop
over it so I'll say let phone of phone
forms controls and while performing this
loop we also want to keep track of the
index which we can do with let I equals
index now each item in this loop is
going to be a form group so we need to
pass the form group name which is just
the index when dealing with a form Group
array now we can set up the form fields
just like we've done in all the previous
examples passing at the form control
name the main difference is that we now
need to populate this array with some
items which we'll do on a button click
so we can set up a material button down
here then we'll run our ad phone event
handler when this button is clicked so
that button lives outside of the loop
but then to delete an item we want to go
back inside of our for loop and add the
delete method to a button as well so
make sure you're inside of ng 4 and then
add your button inside of there and this
time bind it to the delete phone method
and pass it the index as an argument now
we know how to build large dynamic forms
but we're going to need to validate the
user input into these forms the one
thing I haven't shown you yet is that
the reactive form has a whole bunch of
different states that it can be in for
example it can be valid if it is passing
all validation rules it's considered
dirty if the user has typed into it it's
considered touched if the user has
entered a form field and then left it
and all of these different states can be
applied to the entire form group as a
whole or they can be used for each
individual control inside of the form
and angular will apply a CSS class for
each one of these states to the form so
you can use it to control the styling
based on the state that the form is in
fortunately angular material does most
of this for us right out of the box as
you can see here if we don't apply a
ballot email it's going to give us this
message that says your email does not
look right but as soon as we enter a
valid email that error message goes away
we can also show different messages
based on the type of error that's
received for example we might say five
is too young to use this app while 99 is
too old to use this app and then you'll
also notice that we have a submit button
down here at the bottom that buttons
disabled until the form is completely
valid that's a very important technique
because it often prevents the user from
submitting bad data to your back-end
database let's go into the typescript
and we'll import validators from angular
forms angular comes with a bunch of
built-in validators that will cover 90%
of your validation use cases for each
form property we'll set up the default
value and then as the second item in
that array we'll pass another array with
a series of validators I'd like to point
out that you can pass in another array
after this with asynchronous validators
but that's a topic for another video
for right now we just want to
synchronously validate that our email is
required and that it's a proper email
format then we also want to validate
that our passwords required and we can
also pass in a regular expression here
to make sure that that password meets a
certain requirement for example we want
to have at least one letter and one
number in the password string then when
validating numeric values we can look at
the minimum and maximum value which we
can use to set up an age range for the
validation it shouldn't be confused with
min length min length is for Strings
that will validate how long a string is
or how many characters are in that
string for numeric values you want to
use min and Max so we'll say the minimum
age is 18 and the maximum age is 65 and
we also have a checkbox in this form so
if we want to verify that that checkbox
is checked we can validate that it is
required and the value is true now a
quick pro tip when working with
validations is that you want to set up a
whole bunch of getter
for the various fields in your form this
will just make your HTML way cleaner as
you're setting up logic in there to show
different error messages for different
fields now if we jump over to the HTML
we can use the material error component
along with ngf to conditionally show
error messages because we set up that
getter we can just say ng if email is
invalid and if the email has been
touched then we want to show this error
message in other words if the user tried
to enter an email and it wasn't correct
we want to notify them that they need to
correct that then another cool thing we
can do with angular material is show
hints for more complex values for
example for our password we want to give
them a hint that it requires one letter
and one number then if they still enter
it wrong we can say your password sucks
with a validation error so that's pretty
cool for just showing error messages
when we know the entire form value is
incorrect but we have multiple
validators for our age field so we might
want to show a different error message
based on the type of validation error
for example we have a minimum age error
and if we get that error we want to show
a different error message than if it's
the max age so if the user enters an age
that's less than 18 then we're going to
show this message that says your actual
age is too young to use this app then we
can follow the exact same process for
the max age here but just change some of
the details if you have a ton of error
messages like this you might want to map
them to an object in the typescript
one of the nice things about reactive
forms is that you can handle some of the
logic in the HTML and some of the logic
in the typescript depending on your use
case then the last thing we'll look at
is how to disable the submit button for
that we can simply bind the disabled
attribute to the form invalid state on
the reactive form so that's super easy
and something you'll probably do on
every single reactive form that you
build we finally reached the fifth and
final demo which is how to submit a form
to a back-end database and naturally
we'll use cloud firestore to do that so
let's take everything we've learned and
just build a simple contact form like
you would find on any web site we will
validate it and then after we know it's
been saved in the database we'll show a
success message saying that we
your submission if we go into the
firebase console we should be able to
see the data that we entered in the
reactive form saved to our back-end
database
this next section assumes that you have
angularfire 2 installed along with a
firebase project but you can follow the
same principles for any back-end so we
have a basic reactive form following the
principles that we've already covered
what we'll do now is import our angular
firestore database as well as the tap
and first operators from rxjs the form
submission is asynchronous so we're
gonna have a couple of different state
items here loading and success which
will both start off as false the next
thing we need to do is create an event
handler for when the form is submitted
this method will be triggered when the
user clicks the submit button on the
form the first thing we'll do is set the
loading state to true then we'll grab
the current value from the reactive form
and we do that by calling my form value
then I will set up a try-catch block
here so we can catch any errors that
might have occurred on the back end and
then we'll await the angular firestore
collection which we'll call contacts to
add this form value to the database
after we've awaited that operation to
happen successfully then we'll set the
success state to true but if there's any
errors then we'll just go ahead and log
those to the console then after that
happens we'll set the loading state back
to false then there's really not a whole
lot we need to change to the markup we
want to hide the form once it's been
successfully submitted which we can do
by binding the hidden attribute to the
success state but the most important
part is that we listen to this in GC
then run our submit handler method which
will send the data to the database then
as a final touch down here at the bottom
will add a success notification that
lets the viewer know that their data has
been saved in the backend so hopefully
that gives you a good tool set to build
full stack reactive forms in angular 6
I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and if you're ready
to build more advanced features with
angular forms and firebase consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase comm go get access to new pro
videos every week plus a whole support
network designed to help you get your
app into production faster thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you soon